okay so again please note this is such a
managing everything look exactly the
same sort of except for the web presence
up there okay now how are we going to
use this to arrive at this number in a
similar way okay to get to the present
value of $3,000 we have to on this game
get the digital and then sort of reverse
engineering the fog on okay but then you
want to put a little subheading try
using a table if I have the access to
this table then I can go directly there
I'm going to say print value equals okay
I look at $3,000 and then just like
before I'm going to look for a row and
the column that corresponds to the
interest rate at the time so just like
before he is the sixth row I'm going to
go all the way to the end - there is - a
percent okay that's what I correspond to
in terms of the right row record okay
the numbers four point six two two nine
just like before I multiply just like
when I did future now you four point six
two two nine yeah okay calculator there
what are we going to get
okay so let's just pause and think about
this we all got this answer verse 4 now
a coordination that's clearly if you did
a Center check it clearly is in the same
ballpark it's slightly off what if it is
slightly wat trust trust the bugs would
attack you later on okay
you should check if you did that
correctly you should check if you looked
at the correct row and column are you
contented I selected the right row and
column yeah now I want you to look right
a city's number four point six two two
nine it's the product of their
calculations there's not a bunch of
calculations to produce this okay do you
think it's exactly four point six two
two nine they have done some rounding I
don't know how Jewish to drown in water
but you can see the entire table only
goes to four decimal places but if you
were to actually do the calculations
they do you get extra decimal places all
over the end so that difference there it
might only be like zero point zero zero
zero what are the difference but if
you're doing that over 3,000 dollars and
you're going to have what's the
difference four cents
twelve cents is the difference okay all
right so before I let you have a go is
using this on some other questions I
just want to look a little closer to the
table and I want to raise a question up
here present value right you can see we
started with three thousand dollars and
when we crunch the numbers we said the
present value that is required to get to
this self at the end predictably
is bigger than the actual annuity right
can you remind me why is the present
value bigger than the annuity what is it
about the annuity that led to be small
yeah fantastic so $3,000 that nudity is
shorthand for $3,000 and do it every
single year so it's actually say a
$3,000 immunity is a bit of a misnomer
it's several sums of money all stacked
up on top of each other which is why it
ends up so then okay so therefore if
you're not going to do that continual
investment continual deposits then you
need a bigger sum of money to land on
that future value okay but now I want
you to look at the table
do you notice this is for $1 right okay
this room over here these numbers are
not bigger the premises are nothing at
this Walmart what are these values small
what they're saying is if you use an
annuity you'll need a bigger sum of
money from the annuity over time in
order to get to whatever goal that is
based on these percentages why are the
present values like we're expecting
something bigger but he got something so
we could have thought them over time
that is what usually allows a small
annuity right a small annuity over time
can end up at a really just a large sum
of money okay
but what this is saying is actually the
reverse right you can actually have a
smaller monthly sum of money that you
don't need to reinvest in every year you
just leave it there just let it sit
there and it will end up being the same
as your future now you for this annuity
okay let me try to explain where the
numbers come from and why why this
number is not actually perfectly correct
why not dead sometimes is wrong 0.98 0 4
where is this number come from so I'm
just going to write this question where
do the numbers come from I don't need to
demonstrate these lots of times just
what real numbers
because every other number is exactly
the same okay
first worth one year's two percent what
it represents is the present value of $1
/ remember this is going to get to $1
right what is it / what are you dividing
by well if you have a look back at the
formula sorry I might come back over
here do you see what you're dividing by
it's a compound interesting right
compound interesting okay
now you can see the cottage there we did
it move in here the very first seldom I
looked at was for what are and what is
what's the arm at the end one into it
want to do it right so I are actually
not to not you I played in the article
two percent right so this is actually
0.02 and you told me the end was just
just one right to sedative so this is 1
over 1.0 - what's that you can we get
out fishing 1 / you're not happy doesn't
good yeah so actually I'm I write these
down might be okay to you as well I've
got zero point nine eight three nine two
one five six nine twelve hundred dollars
can you see where their numbers come
from it just rounded this to four
decimal places
Thanks do you see why it's more like
smaller
you're dividing by a number that's
bigger than one right if I did 1/5 that
is the a smaller number one divided by a
hundred even though that's what a very
big number still be good one that's all
you need okay so in other words how
would compound interest work you take
your 98 cents right take a 98 cents or
98 question four cents and then you put
it in the bank for one year and it would
get two percent interest right so you
can just reverse this you can say
ninety-eight cents are put in your 0.98
go ahead and put into factor that's 98
cents and if it gets one gear interest
you multiply by 1.0 in this case - 2 / 2
percent and when you see it equals do
you see how Jess Schaben all I've got
idea for no no no it's around on ya so
the reason why is it's a case is because
your very first annuity right it doesn't
get interest until the very end of the
year whereas this gets the first years
interest that's why it's smaller okay so
I just need to point that out because
every other number here is bigger it's
over the top row that's a bit weird but
you would never really put in an annuity
for 1 year anyway the point you to do it
over some period of time does that make
sense